The mysterious life of developers has been incomprehensible for a long time...
...until now.
This is one of the most common species of developer.
This is the "cliche developer" which can be spotted by the conference t-shirt...
...and the pale skin.
The main source of nutrition is a black carbonated liquid,...
...which is devoured in a large quantity.
This separates him from the more rare "hipster developer"...
...observed here.
This species only drinks warm liquids based on expensive spices and beans...
...and his only tool is a so-called Macintosh.
The hipster developer will often refuse to work with tasks...
...such as SQL databases or Java.
Notice how this specimen also makes use of the trackpad...
...attached to his portable Macintosh.
For many individuals in the herd, it is considered prestigious...
...to not utilize this unit at all.
The herd all work together towards a common goal,...
...a goal set by the project owner.